for several years now I have been
creating a series of personal videos as
a YouTube content producer in the field
of philosophy that had to do with my
philosophical commitments and
developments my viewers and subscribers
and followers in various social media
including YouTube have been asking for
this so I talked a bit about why I went
through you know this particular phase
and about where my current interests and
commitments lie my long-standing you
know off on the horizon projects this
one is a little bit different because
this has to do with something you might
say that is more global I wanted to talk
about why it is that I engage in
philosophy on YouTube in the first place
what what it is that I'm actually doing
here so I thought this could be quite
useful for some of the people who asked
about this what I'm going to do is tell
you the five answers that as I give a
lot to it I've worked out about why it
is that I do what I do here and before
that I'd like to tell you a little bit
about the back story of how I got into
this how it grew you know where things
have gone for me with the YouTube
channel I also give you know the five
answers in a bullet point form right at
the start before that though I want to
say a little something we're pretty
rapidly approaching forty thousand
subscribers and four million views which
is actually pretty good for a YouTube
channel that doesn't do cat videos or
other things along those lines and in
philosophy doesn't do high production
you know animations five minutes what I
do is as you know these extended
lectures where it's very high content
very focused on the text the thinker
unpacking the ideas getting them across
to a wide audience without losing too
much of the rigor
that that's involved so you know the
fact that so many people have have
watched these and so many people
commented and so many people have become
regular subscribers is incredibly
gratifying and I think is a great sign
for the fact that philosophy can be done
in real ways on the on the you know new
medium of the internet so let me give
you my five answers in very short form
and like I said I'll talk more about
these in a bit so what are what are the
five reasons why I do what I'm doing I
engage in philosophy on YouTube well the
first one is that it's possible and that
is a big one
that we'll talk a lot about that the
second is that I think that it's it's
needed the third one is that it turns
out that I'm a good fit for what people
are looking for on this medium the fifth
is that I enjoy it and I get some
satisfaction out of it and the fifth is
that it helps to provide a portion of
how I actually earn my living as
somebody who is outside of the Academy
so I'll talk about each of those in turn
but before that I wanted to go over a
bit of backstory some of you may have
heard this in part here and there with
me talking about this in other videos or
in some of the interviews that I've done
on podcasts and in other places but I
think it's well worth talking about so
I've been doing this now for about six
years a little bit over six years and
the story goes back a little bit before
that one of the things that I received
as a present for my 40th birthday was
what we call a flip cam and it's not
quite exactly the same as this one this
is a more recent acquisition but it's
the main the same sort of thing actually
it was there was a company called flip
at the time and they made these little
cameras they didn't hold that much their
batteries ran out fairly quickly they're
quite a bit all clearer than this more
advanced
Kodiak version but is same general idea
right and it was part of the digital
revolution in cameras and I was supposed
to use this to you know take video of my
kids and the trip that I was on and all
of that sort of stuff and I did some of
that but in a very haphazard way then
fast forward a bit to 2011 and spring
semester the last semester that I was at
Fayetteville State University my fiancee
at the time now now wife and my partner
and reason IO who's very innovative and
entrepreneurial person who also you know
was sort of an early adapter very
enthusiastic one for for tech and II she
suggested to me that what I should
consider doing is what's called lecture
capture which means essentially video
recording what's going on in the
classroom and this can be done in a
variety of ways we actually do do you
know a lot of interesting workshops on
that so if you're interested in that
email me so side note in any case what I
started doing was I was teaching for
critical thinking classes for sections
of the exact same class back-to-back
three days a week and I would get a flip
cam like this and I took a tripod and if
I have it one of them here and there may
not have it with me and the tripod is
very small I could plunk it down on a
desk and that is exactly what I would do
I would come in students would file in
I'd have the camera sitting on a desk
and it would be focused on me and the
chalkboard every once in a while student
might bump it it's good cop frame or
something like that but for the most
part it was okay and I video recorded
those lectures and at that time YouTube
didn't allow you to to you know upload
things that were 45 minutes long which
is about how much footage I would get
out of each of these classes so we
loaded them into the institutional
Channel and I'll actually put a link to
this below in the video Fayetteville
State you know has ownership over
were those and it's interesting because
they actually do have a channel but most
of the the views of their channel come
from the videos that that I created they
have not done much more with it since
then and I had somebody on the tech end
there who is also helping out loading
these videos into the institutional
channel so people started watching these
and commenting on it and I started
playing around with my own video
recording I started shooting these
videos that we called dr. Sadler chalk
and talk and the reason why I called the
chalk and talk is because all the
education experts were saying lecture is
dead you have to make things interactive
for the students or you're going to lose
them and so this is me sort of like
thumbing my nose and saying you know
what if you do lecture well people will
in fact watch it if your lecture has
some real meat to it you don't need
quite so many bells and whistles to hold
people's attention so it was actually
kind of a shot in the dark for me but
those those got quite a bit of watching
time and I started video recording some
of the presentations that I was doing at
conferences you know and and at
workshops as well so that was something
that was it was quite interesting and as
I said I would not have considered doing
this myself had Andy not been an
enthusiastic booster and cheerleader
saying look you should you should try
this out you've got nothing to lose I
was much more pessimistic thinking well
you know I'm not a big name in
philosophy these are very low tech who's
going to want to watch these things and
something really surprising came out of
this first of all the videos that I was
creating for my class started getting
watched that semester worldwide and a
lot of the comments by the people who
are watching them were along the lines
of oh thank you for putting this online
my professor is terrible at explaining
this or
I just couldn't understand this or we
went over this and then they wouldn't go
back over it again or you know all sorts
of you know worries like that and I I
you know I knew that when it comes down
to it I was a pretty good teacher and I
also knew that a lot of my peers are not
particularly good at teaching when it
comes to philosophy they they're often
good at writing or doing other things
but but they're they're often not
particularly good at dealing with
students but I was surprised that the
sheer volume of this and that also
started coming up with some of the other
videos that I was doing as well now I
left Fayetteville State University after
organizing university-wide assessment
and helping them write their tenure
quality enhancement plan being up for
early tenure and promotion I left all
that behind it was a whole story about
that that perhaps I'll do a video on
some other time and I moved up to New
York essentially because we were doing
this long distance relationship and
going from North Carolina to New York
was was quite a drag so now we were we
were together you know in one place Andy
and I and I started teaching for Marist
College and I did the same thing there I
started recording my lectures but now I
uploaded them into my youtube channel in
part because you could actually upload
longer videos and in part because you
know Maris wasn't like Fayetteville
State University asserting you know
intellectual property rights over the
stuff that I produced it was my
intellectual property and now I was no
longer teaching critical thinking I was
teaching things that had a bit more
substance you know intro to philosophy
and ethics and I have my students read
primary text so we're reading Plato and
Aristotle and Thomas Hobbes and
Descartes and you know going on and on
and on so so as recording stuff no
longer just from a textbook but from the
classics and those caught on very
quickly as well and people started
saying the same sort of comments you
know my professor is not explaining this
to me I'm not understanding the text
your videos are helping me out with this
a lot of other people started saying
things like I've been out of college for
a long time and I wished I could go back
i watch your videos because it gives me
the feeling of being in a classroom or I
can't afford to go to college so I'm
using your videos as a resource and
eventually it got to the point where you
know not only were students and lifelong
learners using them but also other
professors were you know watching my
videos to sometimes get ideas about how
to teach the material or see whether
they were on the right track or
sometimes just for enjoyment and then I
started shooting other videos and other
sequences outside of the classroom you
notice that chalkboard behind me and
those that lighting stuff those are
investments that I made we made rather
over time after we determined that I
should no longer simply rely on being
able to find an open class room to shoot
a video or have a class on it we should
actually take control over the video
production process and that is in fact
what we have been doing I also now
recently acquired a voice recorder with
a lapel mic that that we use as well and
I started you know shooting other series
like the existentialist series right
existentialist philosophy and literature
or one-offs like on plato's ion or on
Humes you know Natural History of
religion things that I hadn't talked
about in class and then I started
shooting core concept videos use much
shorter you know 10 to 25 minute videos
focused on one particular issue or
distinction or or argument in a
philosophical text and those have been
you know incredibly helpful for people
as well and then I started the half-hour
Hagel series and I started doing other
things like spinning off additional
channels like a critical thinking
argumentation and logic channel or a
history of ideas channel and I've use
the videos as the core for other larger
things like online classes so you know
I've been engaging in this for a law
time and it's grown and it's grown in
its growth because people you know do
like the kind of work that I'm doing and
I you know once again I have to say that
I would not have really thought of doing
this myself had it not been for my at
that time fiance now wife suggesting it
and then suggesting it's more and
suggesting it some more and sticking
with it so that's that's some some
background stuff some back story and I
think viewers might be interested now
let's talk about my answers to these
questions why do I engage in philosophy
on YouTube so answer number one is it's
possible you know the Internet has
become in some respects a great
equalizer when it comes to you know
breaking in in other respects of course
the big players are the big players may
have many more resources than than we do
but the sort of thing that I have been
doing wouldn't have been possible say 20
30 years ago where you needed a lot of
you know studio stuff to do video
production and you know it was really
confined to whoever was interested in
the tech or to prestige projects that
were put about you know you think about
things that have been around for a while
like like the great courses for example
they invite in people who they think are
going to be big drawers and they throw a
lot of money at stuff you know some
other things like Khan Academy started
out very small on YouTube and then other
people were like this is great let's
throw some money at them and they
suddenly became very big there's there's
other institutions like say for example
the Sailor Foundation who use other
people's materials and sometimes produce
a bit of their own they've used some of
mine for example there existentialism
classes for me you know the idea that if
I want to for my students first
all produce resources that I have
control over and I can decide you know
what goes where at what time what's
going to be most helpful for for them is
incredibly liberating and the idea as
well that if I do good work people are
going to share it and notice it and you
know talk about it there's something
there as well and so the internet makes
this this sort of thing possible the
second answer to this question why do I
engage in philosophy on YouTube is it's
needed
it really is needed it's surprising
because we have a whole world of people
out there who could be producing content
for YouTube many of them are you know in
on this particular philosopher more
competent than I am I'm sort of a
generalist you know I have my interests
extended into many different people
which means that I don't you know get to
study quite as much Hegel as somebody
who is specializing as a Hegel scholar
and doesn't have to you know do all this
other stuff on the side and may not
actually know all that much about the
other stuff as well be in part because
they don't want to but here's the thing
very few people are in fact doing this
what's needed is people to produce
content that becomes publicly available
on these you know philosophers these
texts there's certain aspects of it that
are really important you gotta actually
know what you're talking about so that
eliminates some of the people who shoot
the videos and you know there's there's
others who don't shoot the videos who
could be doing it you also have to be
able to be on camera right and many
people get very nervous about that it's
probably as scary as public speaking is
for many people strangely for professors
you know who are okay at being in a
classroom you think they would be okay
with being on video but many of them are
there are huge huge gaps even today in
the materials that are available on even
quite important philosophers and I am
doing my best to remedy these gaps
shooting on average now about 250 videos
per year
you know I concentrate on certain
figures so I have a lot of material for
example on Aristotle's Nicomachean
ethics there isn't that much more that
needs to be done on mantle there's a few
places where I could say a bit more
about it I'm just finishing up a series
on Aristotle's categories I've got you
know quite a bit of stuff out there on
Epictetus as a stoic that there's other
Stoics that I should be concentrating on
as well because there's so few people
shooting video and you know there's
plenty of people shooting you know five
to ten minute clips with lots of glitz
and stuff like that but there's very
little substance to those those leave
people rather hungry and this goes to
the other part of it's needed there is
an incredible hunger out there right now
for substantive engagement with ideas
it's not being satisfied by our academic
institutions when it comes to the
general public it's not being satisfied
by our media including educational
channels it's not being satisfied by the
you know high production let's do a five
minute clip on Descartes stuff either so
you know there's a real need for for the
kind of work that that I'm doing and
over time we're building a body of work
think about the half hour Hegel series
when I may actually finish with that in
another two years hopefully there will
be a video commentary consisting of
about 300 videos that leads think the
leads anybody who wants to study Hegel
through one of the most difficult works
of Western philosophy the phenomenology
of spirit let's talk about the third
answer which is that I am a good fit I
didn't realize that as it turns out one
of the talents that I have
and I'll talk a little bit about how
this happens because the case is taking
complex philosophical ideas thinkers tax
and talking about them in such a way
that that non academics and non
philosophy majors can learn about them
can come away with a solid understanding
without watering the stuff down it's
very very difficult to do that
apparently for many people because
they're great at watering the stuff down
and then it's watered down or they talk
at a very high level of theory without a
lot of examples and analogies and
relating it or perhaps they talk in such
a way that they just you know turn off
the viewers so there's it's hard to get
those two together and as it turns out
that is one of the things that I'm
particularly versed in and that came
about not because of any I think great
talent on my part but by putting in year
after year after year of teaching what
we call service classes that's critical
thinking intro to philosophy ethics
philosophy of human nature these these
very basic level classes that we teach
to non majors those are some of the
hardest classes to teach they're the the
least compensated for um and so there's
very little prestige but if you do them
well you have the opportunity to reach
far more people than in any other venue
that you might be in so that's that's
that was the the apprenticeship that
went through that's where I learned my
my craft and as it turns out I you know
I mentioned that the fear that people
have about being on camera I don't have
that fear for whatever reason I never
did my main worry is about whether I'm
expressing myself well so sometimes I'll
let you in on a little secret at the
beginning of videos I may do a number of
takes where I get you know a few
sentences into it or a minute into it
and I'm like this is no good I got to
start again right I did that actually in
this video but once I get rolling
I really don't have any any problem
keeping keeping the discourse going in
part because I'm explaining stuff that
that you know matters to me so all of
this makes me a particularly good fit
for being able to fill in these these
gaps that I'm saying are out there and
satisfy this demand that that's there
for substantive engagement with ideas
for talking about philosophy without
talking down to people so that is the
third thing let me talk about the the
fourth answer to why it is that I engage
in philosophy on YouTube and that is
quite simply that there is a lot of
enjoyment and satisfaction on my own
part and this fits in a little bit with
the first reason about it's possible
right I you know I'm somebody who has
engaged in traditional academic
publication you know I used to write
anywhere between two to three academic
articles year I've written a book which
is actually a set of translations with a
huge hundred page introduction and
massive chronological bibliography isn't
about a debate that took place in the
1930s in France I I did my time as an
academic and I enjoy doing that sort of
thing and I also do enjoy going around
and doing public speaking and I also do
enjoy the other activities that I engage
in outside of the Academy doing the
consulting work as a you know
philosopher for instance with ethics
consulting doing the public speaking
doing the you know tutorials and the
philosophical counseling and coaching I
love doing all of that stuff but I also
love shooting these videos I love being
able to go to the channel and look and
see that I have actually covered all of
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics or you
know that I'm 180 video installations
into the half-hour Hegel series and that
you know I'm close you know two years
away from being able to provide an
entire commentary in video form on this
this
work that at this point you know tens of
thousands of people have watched and
used for for their own study of Hegel
there's an incredible satisfaction that
comes from knowing that I am providing a
service that you know people really do
appreciate and that's needed that's
particularly needed in our times as we
you know move into this new millennium
and we're working with new media this is
this is absolutely vital as far as I'm
concerned and I try to bring other
people into it you know I give coaching
advice quite often to other people who
are trying to do the same work that I'm
doing whether they're in academia or
outside of academia so there's there's a
lot of satisfaction there that helps to
sustain me the fifth answer to why it is
that I engage in philosophy on YouTube
is that it does also help me to earn my
living now the YouTube itself does not
pay for very much quite frankly you know
the advertisements on on videos at one
time we're paying much more to us
YouTube creators than they currently do
right now you know it's a pretty
surprising how little it actually
provide and that's just life but what I
found is that people watch the videos
and they say well I like the way this
guy teaches so maybe I should take an
online class with them or if they have
the resources or they know other people
who do they say I'd love to hear this
guy speak let's bring him in to do a
talk or they they say you know this guy
seems like somebody I'd like to work
with all hired him as a tutor or as a
philosophical counselor or coach to work
with me on you know learning something
or on issues or you know people contact
me for consulting gigs and that's that's
a very important aspect I should also
mention that I am going to be
creating a patreon page for this this
YouTube and everything else that I'm
doing as well
because people have been asking for that
it seems like a really great idea to me
now let me talk now that I've gone
through those five answers right and I
told you a little bit about the
backstory let me tell you a little bit
about the plans because people are also
you know sometimes asking about this and
sometimes expressing worries I have no
plans to get off of YouTube anytime that
I can think of as a matter of fact yes
if YouTube remains more or less the same
sort of thing I mean who knows what it's
going to look like 20 years from now but
let's assume that things remain more or
less equal I can see myself still
producing content 20 years from now not
only because like I said I do actually
enjoy it
or it's possible but also because I
think by that time there's still going
to be so many thinkers and so many texts
that have not been satisfactorily
discussed and and maybe I'll be able to
do stuff at a higher level around that
time as well you know discussing things
that I didn't get to in the past people
are saying well okay you're presenting
me - what's your criticism of Nietzsche
well I don't have time to talk about
that right now right or you know how do
these these different thinkers connect
with each other there is so much that
can be worked on with with YouTube that
I you know I think I found one of my
callings in life which is producing
these videos so that that is what I've
got lined up you know some of the things
that I have in my mind for going on in
the future are you know doing a series
for example on political philosophy
that's something I'd love to do love to
get back and finally finish up that
existentialist philosophy and literature
series there are literally thousands of
core concept videos that I I would like
to produce
I want to use this half-hour hagel
methodology with you know first reading
the text and having the text available
on the screen and then commenting on it
portion my portion to all sorts of other
texts ranging from you know Cicero to
you know Aristotle's other works to Rene
Descartes to you know everybody else
quite frankly you know there's more than
enough work for for me to do for the
foreseeable future the only question is
it has to be sustainable for me in the
way that I actually earn my living
so that that's the problem probably the
main restriction on things how much time
do I have to spend doing other things
that are living as opposed to shooting
videos that unless you know people start
you know supporting or something like
that aren't quickly earning much of it
but I really love doing this I think
that it's a valuable thing for me to be
engaged in influence a lot of really
great discussions and relationships and
even some some friendships worldwide
with people who I otherwise would not
have come into contact with so you know
that's where all closed thinking about
how wonderful it is that we live in a
time where just you know looking at your
phone you can learn about Plato or learn
about st. Anselm or learn about Hegel
and if you want you can actually say
something in your response so that's
where we'll leave off